wie viel alltag geht noch trotz
flüchtlingskrise und trotz corona man
kann ja nicht alles absagen sonntag zum
beispiel ist kommunalwahl in bayern ja
und zu dieser wahl hat sich bayerns
landesvater markus söder oder welchen
zeitlichen nenner unser schatten kanzler
man richtig gute aktion ausgedacht da
wird nämlich jeder einzelne bayer
persönlich adressiert hallo nadine
wahrscheinlich überrascht dich direkt
persönlich von mir zu hören
hallo naomi wahrscheinlich überrascht
schließlich direkt dass sie nicht von
mir zu hören
hallo nick wahrscheinlich bist über das
direkt persönlich von mir zu hören
hallo nicole wahrscheinlich überrascht
dich direkt persönlich von mir zu hören
hallo nikolaus wahrscheinlich bist du
überrascht direkt persönlich von mir zu
hören
hallo nina wahrscheinlich überall
ausschließlich direkt persönlich von mir
zu hören
hallo oliver wahrscheinlich überrascht
dich direkt persönlich von mir zu ich
bin in der tat überrascht direkt
persönlich von dir zu hören markus vor
allem bin ich überrascht dass der
ministerpräsident von bayern zeit hat
alle deutschen vornamen aufzusagen
und das war übrigens nicht die einzige
tolle csu idee an die scheuer mister
jedoch egal was die maut kostet will
jetzt ein sogenanntes mobilitätszentrum
gründen in dem der verkehr der zukunft
erforscht wird kostet gerade mal 500
millionen euro und entsteht in da kommen
sie nie drauf münchen richtig bezahlt
mit bundesmitteln aber in münchen und
das verkündet unser an die zufällig
genau in der woche vor der kommunalwahl
sachen gibts und zum schluss sage ich
euch kann diese mimimi gesellschaft
nicht mehr sehen
ja das passt gut wir können dich auch
nicht mehr sehen als verkehrsminister
immer noch im amt trotz maut desaster
gestern hat der maut
untersuchungsausschuss erfahren wichtige
daten zum skandal sind aufs handy
gelöscht worden
so unfassbar somit kommt er dennoch
durch man es geht alles unter in dieser
corona nachrichtenlage
wir schalten mal live zu albrecht
humboldt er leitet scheuer social media
abteilung im verkehrsministerium der
umwelt wie sind dann so die reaktionen
im netz zum beispiel auf das geplante
mobilitätszentrum in münchen
das wird sie sehr enttäuschen herr welke
aber ich kriege hier nur geile
reaktionen übrigens auf alles was wir
raus hauen
bei facebook bei twitter baitinger unser
herrscher hat ohne ende fans gerade bei
den jungen wählern warum weil dir genau
die sachen ins netz ballern die die kids
lieben so was hier heiße beats mit dj
andi und dem csu tanzorchester
groovy warte mal da kommt schon die
ersten kommentare was soll der scheiß
tritt endlich zur rückbuchung nähe ist
rheuma weiter dem ist nichts zu peinlich
rücktritt drei ausrufungszeichen noch
nicht so klar hier jetzt aber ich liebe
blasmusik ps tritt zurück
ja ist ja auch egal das prinzip ist klar
geworden absolut ich würde gerne noch
einmal auf das mobilitätszentrum
zurückkommen ihr chef an die scheuer
träumt von einem und ich zitiere
wörtlich mobility valley also ein
mobilitäts tal in münchen verkündet
direkt vor der kommunalwahl ist das
nicht wahlkampfhilfe für die csu mit
bundesmitteln also erst mal ist das
tradition bayern kriegt immer ein
bisschen mehr als alle anderen
bundesländer dafür ist man ja bayern
zweitens wird das wunderschön ich zeige
ihnen mal was wir da planen hier zum
größenvergleich die münchner
frauenkirche und dann in sichtweite
unser mobility valley
da ist jeder cent steuergeld top
angelegt selbstverständlich mit
landeplatz für flug taxis vor dem
eingang die zwölf meter große granit
statue von andy schoy auf einem elektro
roller und oben an der kuppel hängt eine
minute nur die addiert in realtime alle
verspätungsminuten der deutschen bahn
wunderbar kostet 500 millionen
lustigerweise fast genau die summe die
wir auch bei der pkw-maut verbrannt
fanden wir irgendwie komisch muss man
dabei gewesen sein
wahrscheinlich jetzt habe ich gelesen an
die scheuer hat auch noch geld das für
fahrradwege geplant war für
bundesstraßen ausgegeben moment in
unserem etat waren noch 50 millionen für
den bau von neuen fahrradwegen an
bundesstraßen übrig das stimmt so und
von dem was da übrig war hatte an die
wohl zwölf millionen genommen und nicht
für fahrrad kram ausgegeben sondern für
neue bundesstraßen weil wir da mehr bock
drauf hatten totale unverschämtheit und
direkt danach posten wir sowas hier
ich bin verkehrsminister und damit auch
fahrrad minister und da kommt schon der
erste kommentar der helm sieht scheiße
aus tritt zurück
dem kann ich mich nur anschließen
albrecht humboldt vielen dank alter
der club hatte er wieder alles wahnsinn
inhaltlich stark satire comedy gold ich
habe es noch drauf also ich würde den
kanal direkt abonnieren und auf gefällt
mir drücken wenn ich das nicht so getan
hätte das war wirklich stark
[Musik]